what happens when scp-914 gets in the  Halloween spirit entered snevitz  prepared one plastic skeleton one Freddy  Krueger animatronic Halloween decoration  and a variety of assorted Halloween  themed baked goods for experimentation  all of the above items were placed into  the Clockworks on the setting fine the  output produced was a humanoid  animatronic designed to look like a  generic Baker possessing a Cognito  hazardous effect causing the viewer to  believe that a recent baking competition  later found to not have actually  occurred Was Won by a team made up of  nine heavily mutilated corpses this  effect did not prevent the viewer from  realizing how unusual such an event  would be